[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
endgame class my name is Caleb Dendy and
I will be taking you through some pretty
interesting end games that we saw from
the chest film Masters Tournament once
again the first one I wanted to start
off with is actually a game that I guess
was not too relevant to the overall
standings of the tournament but was a
very interesting end game nonetheless
it's a game between Maxime viola graph
and timur raja baath so let's jump in
and see what happened in this game this
is what's known as the opening in chess
and this is an endgame class so I'm
going to flip through these moves very
very quickly if you want to see opening
analysis be sure to watch
chess openings explained on Monday
however that's not where we're about and
now already many pieces have been traded
off the board as early as move 23 here
and so I sort of wanted to start talking
about the position from somewhere along
these lines it was a pretty interesting
position that they ended up hitting here
and I wanted to get the chatrooms
thoughts on what was happening in this
position because we do have some
imbalances here at first glance it looks
very level but we do have quite a number
of imbalances going on so let's talk
about them first off we have the
difference in the queenside pawn
structure we have this pawn on c5 for
white and a2 for white versus this a7
and b7 pawn these pawns for black
additionally we have the bishop pair for
white versus a bishop and night for
black with an extra set of Knights on on
the board as well finally one last
difference we do have white with this
pawn already extended out to e4 versus
this pawn still sitting back on
seven so chatroom what do you guys think
about this initial what I'm calling
endgame position here you could argue
this is still somehow like a you know
sort of a middle game but I think it's
it's fair to say we're in a kind of an
endgame here so so what do you guys
think would you rather take white or
black in this particular position
notably also white is making a threat of
Bishop takes c6 so this is something
that that black is going to have to deal
with as well so what do you guys think
right off the bat here
when does the late middle game end in
the end game begins
there's not really a solid science to it
it's sort of just what chess players
have decided to name different portions
of the same game really it's all the
same chess game so some players like to
define it as when the King can actively
play in the game without having to worry
about checkmates but then you do end up
in major peace and games which are quite
clearly end games but end games in which
the King should not be coming out to
play so difficult to say the chat room
likes White's because he has the two
bishops and Mark two pieces white with
two bishops and tempos seems better
Auguste says black is better white
despite the g7 bishop so I am sort of
inclined to favor the white pieces here
and let me talk to you a little bit
about why that is
first of all yes there's this problem of
Bishop takes c6 to deal with but even
structurally I'm not so sure I would be
quick to claim that the c5 a to pawn
structure is actually worse than the a7
b7 pawn structure now when I was listing
imbalances I sort of heavily implied
that one would prefer to have the pawns
connected on a7 and b7 but in this case
especially with this Bishop on e3 very
solidly backing up this pawn on c5 this
is a huge restriction to black structure
it's going to make it very difficult to
mobilize the black pawns and with this
pressure here it's actually white who
has pressure on the black pawns it's
black who has weaknesses to deal with
rather than
white also the two bishops sort of speak
for themselves in this position they are
going to be quite active so I do agree
with you guys that that white is is
going to be a bit better there are some
people who disagree though although
beltron I think has just said the wrong
color because he listed a bunch of
advantages for whites and then study
thinks black is the one with them
dynamic position better player wins
you like black for the better potential
peace activity in the e4 pawn may need
the King to watch it so yes this is the
last sort of pawn imbalanced that that I
mentioned and in general in these end
games
I do think white would prefer to have
this pawn on e3 or e2 and most like pure
rook end games or minor piece end games
the pawn on e4 is perhaps maybe a little
bit too far extended now as far as F for
an e5 coming on the board I'm not sure
this is something that white is really
interested in doing either now as far as
this being a huge weakness though I do
think the move F 3 is going to be
solidly enough for black to comfortably
cover the e4 pawn so I'm not so sure
that it is the most relevant weakness
here although I will say perhaps white
would feel better obviously in this case
the bishop is on a3 so it'd be tough for
this phone to be on e3 but maybe with
not with this pawn not being on e4 in
fact if these pawns were off the board
maybe white would feel a little bit
safer but that's not a huge deal in this
case in this game
black chose to move Knight d7 in order
to protect the rook to deal with this
pin notably this move also hits the
knight but now the knight comfortably
jumps in to the d5 square and now a
second advantage of this pawn being back
on the starting square is that against a
move like 95 the move east six is
playable now here though
the move Knight d4 comes on the board
for white and this is a pretty natural
move just increasing the pressure to
this c6 square in the game Knight d2 e 5
was played
and now white makes a pretty significant
mistake I will say it's a move that that
sort of almost already flips the
advantage in to Black's favor in this
case what was called for was some
slightly more simple moves moves like
King G 2 and you sort of just allow
black to show his hand say okay player
with the black pieces timur raja baath
what do you want to do I have more space
I'm happy to sit here for a little bit
maybe I will even consider playing moves
like f4 and hints at things like f5 or a
5 at a later date also I am the one who
can comfortably actively switch to the
open file sort of whenever I deem
necessary what are you doing here and
more like more than likely black would
start playing things like a six and this
Bishop could retreat and just trying to
simplify things a little bit I wouldn't
be surprised to see the game follow
lines similar to these and I think with
these simplifications White's advantage
actually only becomes more clear is it
enough to win I'm not so she's not not
so certain but I do think it is a
comfortable edge now for white with the
pr2 to bishops so I think now was kind
of cause for just a waiting game and
slowly improving the position for white
instead white plays this move Bishop a4
which you could argue is an attempt to
do sort of the same thing the issue is
that what black now does actually have
very nice moves in this case starting
with the move Knight a5 Roger Bobb
starts playing with some very very
accurate chess 95 may not look like too
much to worry about but after the move
to d1 all of a sudden this Knight is
landing on the c-4 square now this
Bishop is attacked you don't want to
give up this bishop this bishop comes
back to c1 and suddenly out of nowhere
there's no way to defend this pawn for
white so let this be sort of a word of
warning to you if you find yourself in a
position like Maxime vassula graph found
him
at first glance in this position it
almost looks as though nothing can
really go wrong here for white
you know the c5 pawn is solidly defended
we have all this pressure on the
queenside
we can do things sort of however we once
but that's not to say that blacks
position is totally without threats and
very very quickly we saw how easy it was
for raja baath to create this immediate
counter play that MVL was somehow
hopeless to to stop so the move Bishop
a4 was a bit of an inaccuracy I think
because 95 is strong compared ibly if
King g2 followed by Knight a5 black is
our white is very much ready to play the
move 93 and challenge the c6 or the C 4
square if this Knight comes to c4 well
then Bishop f4 is already going to be
pretty nice and just as an example line
be 5 Bishop c1 now it is black with
another weakness on the e5 square as
well bishop f8 not even coming with
tempo now as this guy is attacked and
rook before you can see how easy it
would be in this case for white to kick
out some of these active black pieces so
that's why this bishop kind of belonged
on b5 just guarding the c-4 square a
little bit more closely after Bishop a4
it's sort of asking for it and then is
actually getting it after the move
Knight a5 and even here I think the best
thing for white to do is actually just
admit the mistake and come back to b5
you really do want to be guarding this
square and now if 9 c4 you can capture
perhaps even play moves like Knight a6
and going for some interesting end games
but not the case in this game rip d1
Knight ASC for Bishop c1 bishop FA and
now this pawn does find himself being
indefensible
and yeah Ritesh is asking me why is the
pawn on e4 a problem and yeah I did talk
about it a little bit but I will try to
explain a little bit further it's not so
much that the pawn on e4 is a problem
here for white it's just that it's more
it has more potential to be weak on e4
then it would on a square like e 2
because when you have the pawn on e 2
you always have the option of advanced
to e3 if you need to you can even
advance to e4 if you need to you can
control all of these squares that the
pawn on e4 can no longer control even
immediately you can see the knight on f6
is pressuring this pawn and the stat on
c3 is just slightly mobilized by this
this issue it's not a huge deal though
by any means you're right anyways moving
along rook d1 we do have c6 by nvl this
is the attempt and BL came up with to
get the most out of this dying pawn and
Bishop takes before would be a bit of a
mistake here of course because c7 is
queening by force after the move rook
rook d8 Knight b6 is potentially
playable but moves like Bishop h6 and
all of a sudden this rook is dead so not
not Bishop takes b4 rather but instead
just King g7 by raja baath now f c7 rook
c8 is going to be comfortable enough so
not c7 in this case rather Knight back
to d3 and now Knight takes c6 for raja
baath and of course White was maybe
slightly better with the pawn on c5 in
the two bishops with this pawn now dead
it is of course black who is going to be
solidly better in this endgame now chat
room I wanted to ask you guys another
question here White is sort of at a
crossroads here the move Bishop takes c6
is legal and now this may be your only
chance to take on c6 and force black to
recapture with the b-pawn is this a
trade that you think white should make
in this specific case white or should
white avoid this trade at all
costs or none of the above is it about
equivalent if white makes the trade or
not what do you guys think in in this
case is Bishop takes c6 something that
white wants to do note you're no longer
thinking about winning this chess game
with white you this is just out of your
mind now you were down upon you are
looking to hold in this position so
Bishop takes c6 good decision or bad
decision
make the trade says chess King no
because the rook gets an open file
trade would be bad because of the open
file and passed pawns bad one but you
have more pawn islands and STF eight
eight eight eight pawns will be
fragmented in week so make the trade
good decision no bad so the chat room is
kind of essentially split which is sort
of what I was hoping for and you could
say this is down to a matter of taste
almost whether or not you take on c6 but
I do think in this specific case taking
on c6 does give white better holding
chances then if he doesn't take on c6 so
let's talk about why that is well for
one it's down to calculation there are
principles you can fall back on to say
if Bishop takes c6 is good or bad you
know there's the principle of the two
bishops there's also the principle of
you know having fewer pawn islands then
there's also the principle of you know
weaknesses only weak if it could be
attacked and there's the principle of
you know past pawns are better than not
passed pawns so don't make a passed pawn
but this way of thinking isn't actually
gonna get you very far in an endgame
like this right so what is going to get
you far is calculating in the specifics
so let's talk about the specifics Bishop
takes c6 is a specific right it's a
forcing move B takes c6 must be played
after that some of you correctly pointed
out that it may be a mistake to open up
the open file for the rook so this is a
problem that white will need to solve so
Bishop f4 very forcing move attacks this
rook on b8 so let's say this rook moves
over to c8 works belong behind passed
pawns
so now rook c1 would be very very
sensible trying to attack this guy this
is also a very forcing move this rook
isn't this Knight is attacked so Knight
back to b6 then you can imagine a move
Bishop e3 and all of a sudden you kind
of see that white is very close to
attaining just a perfect setup for
trying to hold this position
by guarding the c5 square with every
piece that he has it's going to be quite
difficult for black to actually break
through in fact you can imagine if I
move like ninety seven sort of trying to
bait white into capturing here and
winning with c5 I move like ninety five
is not actually ridiculous with takes
takes takes in takes I believe this rook
endgame is much closer to being drawn
than it is to to being a win here for
black and some of that comes with
experience some of that comes with what
is now definitely an advantageous e5
pawn pointing out that there's simply no
way you're going to get your King into
this game quite easily for example King
e7 King up 187 okay well maybe that move
is a bit of a mistake but moves like
rook c3 here and the game would would
very much continue so do you need to see
all of this in your head before you go
not necessarily all of it but you should
at least be able to get as far as
something like Bishop f4 noticing that
the Zurich has no opportunities on the B
file and having to switch to a different
file like this and then I move like rook
c1 you can also imagine here and because
we did all this calculation we should be
able to see that we're in time to stop
this pawn from kind of reaching c5
comfortably and if you know even if the
C pawn is passed if it can't get through
even the c5 square the further back the
board it is sort of less threatening a
passed pawn can be and so since the pawn
is so far back I do think that why it
does have good holding chances in this
endgame and this is just honestly it's
not the happiest approach to end games
but I think it's the best approach to
end games you cannot really fall back
solely on principles and positions like
these because you're gonna run into all
sorts of back-and-forth swear you're not
sure what actually matters in the
position and so it's it's just gonna be
down to calculation and that's what end
games really come down to that being
said it's all for nothing
MDL didn't want to take the knight now
am I saying MVL was wrong too
take the night maybe actually in light
of the game continuation honestly though
it's it's tough to say because I do
think White has decent holding chances
in this end game as well where the pawn
is not passed and is instead stuck on b7
in this case night six to a five was
blacks choice supporting this knight on
c4 also removing this Knight from the
threat of capture now white continues
with the move Knight to b2 which is very
very sensible you want to evict this
Knight from its active Square Knight b6
was played in the game and Bishop b2 d2
continues forcing these pieces back and
once again Bishop takes c6 is a playable
move but MVL has now firmly decided he's
against taking this bond so Bishop c3
check instead makes sense King to g8 and
now white makes a very severe misstep
that more or less loses the game
unfortunately for MVL so it's easy to go
wrong in a position like this because
despite being down upon it's not really
felt right you don't really feel like
you're that much down upon in this
specific position meaning you don't
really feel it because the pawns are
sitting back here on a 7 and b7 you know
if these pawns are on b4 an a4 all of a
sudden black would have something to say
and white would be like oh my gosh I'm
down upon I might be losing this game
however in this position it's less clear
so the mistake that white made was
playing sort of a casual move that
actually allowed these pawns to very
much mobilize themselves incredibly
quickly and once those pawns and get
rolling down the board the further down
the board that they get the more
difficult it gets for white to sort of
stop them so what was the correct
approach here chat room what do you
think white should be doing in this
position here
what should white be doing I'll tell you
sort of the general rule white should be
trying to attain and then you tell me
the specific how is it done
so white should be trying to contain
these pawns on the Queen side as much as
possible so how can we
contain the queenside pawns
Rick t7 would be great but unfortunately
black is controlling the square for the
moment so not going to be playable in
this case beltron says a floor nine a
four by auguste invade on d8 has been
suggested also I mean we would love to
invade to these scores but it is looking
rather difficult at the moment Bishop
takes c6 by Edward Lee e5 has been
suggested Knight a 4 and add a 4 then
Turk d7 Bishop d4 has been suggested as
well
and EDD releases isolated pause so we've
talked about Bishop takes c6 and in fact
in this case it is going to be a very
similar case as the ones we've discussed
before Bishop takes c6 is still a
playable move this is a playable end
game for white is it going to be lost I
personally don't think so from the
analysis I've done but it's easy to
understand why you know white isn't
quite so happy to just go straight into
an endgame like this where you do give
the opponent you know a more direct past
pawn but we've talked about it
it all comes down to specifics and in
games like these endgame principles only
get you so far it's going to have to
come down to calculation and in this
case Bishop takes c6 is totally fine you
can follow it up with a four highlight
the fact that this Knight cannot stay
here and the game might continue if
black plays a nonchalant move like
Bishop e7 something like a5 and out of
nowhere it's it's white with the
activity so invading with rook d7 is not
a bad idea at all now what you don't
want to do is go for the move Knight a
for a lot of you said this in the chat
room and you said this with the idea of
very quickly invading with your up d7
and I think this is exactly what MDL was
hoping for unfortunately though this is
the move that allows black to mobilize
these pawns Knight takes say for Bishop
takes a 4 B 5 out of nowhere then a 5 B
4 and this is just ridiculous you can't
stop these pawns it you know it looked
as though these pawns weren't going
anywhere for the next billion years and
now out of nowhere they're both on the
fifth rank heading to the fourth rank
with tempo so that's what happened in
the game and we'll look more at that but
I do think the best move in this case is
going to be the move a4 once again with
the idea of a5 and not only are we
threatening to invade on d7 but we are
very much constricting these pawns by
putting this pawn on a4 so it's
positionally desirable it's tactically
desirable and that's why I think a 4 is
the best move now you can insert the
move Bishop takes c6 if you really want
to but I do think just a 4 first is fine
and actually black might be forced to
contest this file when after rook takes
d8 and they takes d8 in Bishop d4 we
you see that it is white who is able to
very much restrict these pawns for sort
of all eternity in fact it's very very
difficult now to see how black is ever
mobilizing these pawns if you play move
like 9 c8 you're asking for Bishop d7
mighty might be six back and this might
be an immediate draw if you try to
deviate white is happy to snatch this
guy and this is of course going to be
just pure equality with these pawns
being doubled so a4 was the right call
Bishop takes c6 not a bad move either
but I do think a 4 is is even more
direct going for a5 immediately now
Knight a 4 this is the classic mistake
you have to be on the lookout for any
move that allows your opponent to
mobilize these pawns the further up the
board these pawns get the more difficult
it is to stop them so Knight takes a 4
plate in the game this should take say 4
B 5 Bishop back to c2 and rather than
play a5 immediately black actually just
continues with Bishop g7 which is still
also just as good Bishop d2 94 and now
black has active pieces has the act of
pawns and is rolling up the board Bishop
d3 comes on the board and now black
actually has the choice Knight f3 and
Knight takes D 2 is an option available
to black going for an opposite colored
Bishop endgame now of course it's not a
pure opposite colored Bishop endgame as
there are looks on the board so chatroom
what do you think is this a good
decision or a bad decision to go for
this endgame
not sure which position you were talking
about STF 8 8 8 8 but if you're talking
about the positions after 8th floor I
tend to agree that black start square
Bishop wasn't active there because you
know things things were good for white
bad good decision bad bad decision good
good the chatroom is against splits
chatroom is split again opposite colored
bishops are more drawn and black ones to
win chess King says good comments is
good can anybody tell me why they think
is a good decision the people who say
bad decision are giving me some some
thoughts 9 is more active opposite
bishops as jarash good because then the
blacks dark-squared bishop becomes great
it's good you f it's good after you take
you push a 5 B 4 a good decision easier
to push the pawns so in this case I
definitely agree that this was a correct
decision by raja baath ROG Bob did
actually plain out of three and take on
D 2 and I think it is a good call here
because once again it's it's down to the
specifics it's down to what's the
easiest way to get these poems up the
board and I do tend to agree that the
easiest way actually occurs after taking
off this bishop now there is something
you have to look out for here right
there are two squares you have to get by
if you are playing with the black pieces
and you decide to go for an opposite
colored Bishop endgame these are the two
squares you have to be absolutely
certain you are getting across if
there's any doubt in your mind that you
can't get past one of these squares then
it's very very silly to go for the
opposite colored Bishop endgame so the
question is can we get past b3 and the
answer to that question I think quite
clearly is going to be yes with the
bishops off the board why is it yes well
because there's no comfortable way for
the LightSquared bishop for white to
defend the B 3 square it come back to c2
but that's about it C 2 and D 1 are the
only two squares that has available to
it and why should be able to sort of
remove this bishop from one of those
squares thanks to
activity of the rook now b1 also isn't
going to be too much of a problem for
black in the long run with rooks on the
board when rooks are on the board it's a
totally different scenario if it was a
pure opposite color bishop endgame then
maybe with the pot on b2 white would
still have some holding chances but it's
not a pure opposite color bishop endgame
we have a ruckus on the board and with
Rex on the board if the pawn lands on b2
and it's almost always just going to be
a direct win so Knight f3 played in the
game
King g2 and then it takes d2 or it takes
D - and now a five comes on the board
rook c2 is played and now b4 or a4
generally I do think it's better to play
the move a4 in this case it might not
really matter because a4 cannot be
stopped after you play b4 but it's best
practice to push to the light square
first because those are the squares
that's gonna be harder for you to get
past rook c5 was played in the game now
b4 comes on the board rook a5 it's this
a pawn and now rook d8 is sort of a
clever move by raja baath now
potentially playable was just the move
b3 immediately a b3 a b3 but then look
out because white may actually be ending
up holding this game if you do allow
this move rook b5 this is sort of what
MDL was hoping for I think which is why
first we do see the move rook d8 by raja
baath now I think whites only hope was
to play this move Bishop c2 if you play
Bishop c2 you are forcing blacks hand
very much now the worst thing black
could do here is is play the move a3 if
you play the move a3 you are giving up
so so much you may still end up winning
this game thanks to some funny exchange
sacrifice business you can pull but now
the only way you're ever getting b3 b3
to happen is if you're sacrificing this
rook for this bishop that's the only way
b3 is ever happening but thankfully for
black the move rook d2 is quite
interesting and probably quite good here
if Bishop takes a four rook takes a two
and black is still firmly in control in
this position so rook d2 in the game I
continue okay check Bishop f8 takes a
four it takes a two and now it's still
just a question of getting past in this
final light square and I think black
should be able to achieve it in a
position like this also notably with
rooks on the board white is not without
problems on the Kings side either and
that's the issue and these quote-unquote
draw an opposite color Bishop endgames
when you do have that extra piece on the
board it sort of changes the scenario
entirely where your opponent is able to
generate more more threats than you
might expect
so that's how the game could have gone
instead though Bishop a6 was played and
now this is just quite a simple win
after b3 a b3 a b3 now there's no Rick
b5 trick for King rook and pawn and so
this pawn just lands on b2
now with this pawn on b2 like I said
this is sort of just over rook b3 Bishop
c3 it should be 2 or d2 King f1 and
after a few more moves Bishop d3 and the
search just cleans up on the Kings side
and after rook takes h2 MBL had had
enough and resigned this position so
you're really interesting endgame here
between mvl and raja baath we spent
quite a lot of time on it but I did
think it was quite instructive and quite
useful too
- I figure out that is why the pawn on
e4 is a problem yeah in this case the
pawn on e4 actually did end up taking
away squares from the LightSquared
bishop as as well so just to recap the
key points of this game were some
decisions that mvl made and some
decisions that raja baath made so let's
go back to those key decision points and
just review ever-so-slightly
bishop first of all Bishop a4 is is just
a huge mistake you got to be on the
lookout for these sources of counter
play by your opponent to get back into
the game
a move like even a 4 I think would have
been quite good King G - just keeping
the balance quite good as well so Bishop
a4 a huge mistake
now not taking on c6 I'm not going to
call it a huge mistake but I'm gonna
call it sort of a missed opportunity I
think if you take on c6 more often than
not white does end up holding that
endgame thanks to his control over the
c5 square so Bishop b5 instead no night
a6 or night six to a5 rather Knight B to
English ship d2 and Bishop c3 and all of
a sudden out of nowhere white once again
seemingly has things under control all
he needed to do was find the move a4 and
now threatening a5 threatening riff d7
out of nowhere it's once again black
who's sort of on the back foot now
blacks not really in danger of losing
this position ever but I definitely
don't think that black has really any
winning chances if why it launches this
a pawn forward in an effort to contain
the black Queen side so a useful idea to
remember pushing the a pawn forward to
contain these two Queen side pawns it
works in end games it's actually not a
bad idea in many middle games either
pushing this a pawn forward to contain
the Queen side so huge mistake there
instead in Knight a 4 I think is almost
a losing move allowing black to mobilize
the pawns this is the worst case you
cannot allow black to mobilize the pawns
from their raja baath trade it off these
bishops and after pushing these pawns
found some accurate play to end up
winning the game hopefully you guys
enjoyed that one let's move on to end
game number two believe it or not all
the end games today were played by raja
baath not all of them did go his way
though I wanted to talk about this one
and that raja baath had against Fabi
Karen wanna now this is a game where I
will spoil a little bit Bobby ended up
getting rook and Bishop against rook and
I am not in the business of telling you
guys how to play rook and Bishop against
rook with perfect play and that's
because I don't know how I am in the
business though of analyzing the endgame
that they had before they got there and
we're gonna be analyzing this endgame
with the idea in mind that getting rook
and Bishop versus rook is a pretty good
outcome
at any level you may not know all the
tricks to throw it your opponent if you
are the side with the bishop but likely
at your level or at least at my level
your opponent likely isn't going to know
all the best defensive tries either so
we're gonna analyze the endgame with
with that in mind rook and Bishop versus
rook is a pretty favorable outcome I
can't tell you the stats on how often
it's won at the amateur level versus
professional level but I will say you
know you can never lose to reckon Bishop
versus rook unless you try really hard
so let's skip ahead here like I said not
an openings class not a middlegame class
it is an endgame class so let's get
these stupid queens off the board yeah I
hate the Queen's let's get let's get
more pieces off the board I don't know
if I'm ready yet
see a knight takes c3 rook takes c3 and
I think now we can safely comfortably
say we are once again in an endgame and
this is quite an interesting one and
that fabien raja baath had here I say
it's interesting because when you have
both rooks and a minor piece on the
board it's a pretty unique dynamic also
interesting is the sort of scattered
pawn structure that we do see on the
board very scattered pawns in this case
for both players and so it's gonna be an
endgame with a lot of targets for both
players to try to aim at it's gonna be
an end game where both players try to
make their minor piece more useful so
what's you guys's first impression I
like asking this question sort of at the
beginning of the endgame just to the
chat room open question what's your
impression of this position better for
white better for black even what things
do you like about White's position what
things don't you like when things are
good for black open question black to
move as well by the way was that from
today no the MBL raja baath game I
believe was played earlier in the
tournament I don't remember many likes
black cool person five six seven says
black is much better TNS tbh says looks
like 5050
a fiver rook t5r some ideas that manny
has White's better due to the past pawn
white spawns are further and plaque is
overextended black wins well it's true
black does win this game but that's not
to say black is better here because of
king and rook positions so yeah you guys
are looking at all all the right factors
here it's important to always check the
king position and end games like these
and not only in a king position but in
end games where there's two rooks on the
board King's safety is actually going to
be quite relevant as well a nonzero
amount of these end games and in
checkmate without anybody like promoting
a pawn or anything they just get
checkmated by the rooks that definitely
can happen so that's something to be
wary of now I don't think that's gonna
happen in this case cuz both Kings are
pretty safe as four rook position some
people said they liked black because he
has the open file or at least the
potential to get on the open file some
people might actually prefer white
because they're finding that White's
rooks are less tied down than blacks
whites rooks are behind some pretty good
pawns or at least on a half-open file
and whereas the blacks rooks are sort of
staring at at White's pawns you're also
looking at the minor pieces many of you
said that you like black because of the
color of the bishop meaning this bishop
on a dark square can target the white
pawns whereas the white Bishop on a dark
square is sort of stuck behind its own
pawns and these are all definitely very
relevant factors here so how do you go
about evaluating this position with all
that in mind so once again you guys are
taking sort of a principled approach to
the position but once again it's a very
very complex ending with so many
principles in play that it's sort of not
so easy to get an objective answer out
of all those principles they sort of
counterbalance each other right well
Black has this going firm white has this
going for them and I said in the
previous game that the best way to go
making those kinds of decisions is
withdraw calculation in this specific
position I think the best way to
evaluate and I think the best way to
evaluate in many positions is to not
necessarily have to go 30 moves deep in
wrong calculation but to at least
examine the plans so let's examine the
plans for both sides here or at least
potential plans potential ideas for
black we want to be able to improve our
pieces so how can we improve our pieces
well they can put our King on a light
square maybe even on the f5 square and
just sort of hold together this entire
King's side this is a job that the king
can kind of serve now as for active
plans you know we get our King to a nice
lights square a nice safe square active
plans potentially maybe we could think
about trying to attack the King on the
Kings side potentially we could think
about attacking the d4 pawn just
doubling up for example even bringing a
bishop out to f6 piling up on d4 and
maybe we could think about trying to
push on this in this Queen site as well
creating our own past pawn things of
that nature so these are some active
plans
that's a black can can try now we have
to do the same thing for white
regardless of what what side we are you
know it's not enough in chess to come up
with plans for yourself you have to try
and think about what your opponent's
gonna be doing while you're busy doing
all these shenanigans that you have
plans and so what is white going to be
doing well white is going to be likely
pushing this pawn up to c6 at some
moment right
if white can advance this Queen side
pawn then white is going to be very
happy you know putting some more
pressure on the black position why it
also might be trying to open up this a
follow for himself getting the rooks
into the position sort of in this manner
and the meanwhile White's Bishop doesn't
look very good on b2 but it's sort of
defending the only weakness
vanna that white finds himself with
white also might be interested in
targeting this B pond and white might be
is interested in in pushing forward with
d5 as well these are all sort of active
plans
for white so with that in mind both
sides have active plans and neither side
really seems to have a plan that's just
going to be outright giving them
advantage and because of that I'm quite
comfortable calling this position equal
some of you might disagree with that but
I do think that that equal is is a fair
thing to say about this end game both
sides have things to do with their
pieces and neither side seems to be
breaking through particularly quickly
and because of that it's fair to say
that this position is going to be equal
I think in the game Bobby started with
King g6 now bishops III by and whites
and Fabi does bring this route to d5
perhaps hinting at some ideas of this
the King comes over to g2 and now that
Fabi has sort of block hated this Bishop
and he's happy to bring this rook oh
they're over to this open file white now
goes about with his active plan of
attacking on b5 so we see now both
players did end up going for some of
these active plans that we described and
because they're both active enough and
fast enough neither player is really
breaking through first the move a six
was fabi's choice just defend b5 and
then white does actually come through
with the AF or move Fabi at this point
understood that his rook on h8 was not
going to be in time to create tangible
threats so he just swaps
over to the Queen side why does
committed to a four this is now where
the action is going to be and both sides
are flexible enough to sort of deal with
the opening up of the Queen side in this
manner so a takes b5 comes on the board
it takes b5 and now
raja baath plays rook e1 and at this
exact moment I would say raja baath is
creating a tangible threat right if you
pass lookout rookie rook to be one might
be coming on the board and now it's
quite difficult to defend this beep on
so try and find an active idea for Fabi
here I will say it's an idea that I
haven't actually mentioned yet for Fabi
to try and activate some of the black
pieces and create your
rights to sort of counter the the
threats to the beep on
Manny and Mendel both liked the idea of
b4 and believed everybody likes the idea
before king f5 kini for has been
suggested as well if I can draw the
arrow there you go
bishop da indicia peph six has been
suggested
and so yeah the move before is
potentially playable here actually this
wasn't the idea that I had in mind but
it is a nice idea and I will give it to
you guys so if you do end up capturing
here the good news for black is that you
can actually take on d4 and then after
Bishop a3 for example ro takes b2 or it
takes very Bishop takes b2 Brooksie for
hitting this guy Orca c1 trade trade
draw agreed right so b4 is definitely a
potentially playable move for for black
here instead though Bobby did choose the
other choice which I saw some people in
the chair I'm suggesting as well and
that choice is a five and I quite like
this move from a practical perspective
of playing for a win because what does
it do well one it's solving the problem
of the b-pawn right white is always
going to capture this pawn here I'd be a
little bit silly to play move like rook
d1 when black can kind of just get a
better version to move like King f5 so
white always takes and then you can take
on c5 now practically you have your B
pawn well defended on a white square it
has two defenders white can't possibly
add more than two attackers to it
and from a practical standpoint you also
have started targeting this 'if I've
pawn right and the c5 pawn is not upon
that's going to be so easy for white to
defend namely because it's giving your
King an active role in the game the King
can very comfortably step to the e5
square and now it is suddenly attacking
an e5 pawn that's not so easy to defend
and so that's why I like fabi's choice
of e5 here it avoids
math simplifications it does keep some
pieces on the board and it gives fabia
target to play for it Bobby ends up with
an extra beep on just maybe he's gonna
be able to win that game so Rick III was
Raja Bob's choice King f5 was played and
then raja baath does something very very
smart and that's more thing that he does
is play the move f3 he's realizing that
perhaps he's no longer playing for any
kind of advantage with White's because
he did allow black to kind of break
through with the
active plan of e5 and now he's trading
off as many pawns as he can because if
all the pawns fall off the board it's
going to be nature on endgame of course
in this case Bobby chose the move rook
c4 we see the move rook B - E - sort of
defending the last weakness in the white
camp and this allows Fabi to break
through with b4 for a moment F takes G
for was a check this King comes back to
e6 always keeping an eye on this ePHI
pawn here Bishop b2 was played and now
b3 and Fabi is just making this passed
pawn sort of felt on on the Queen side
King f3 was Roger pops choice always
good to get the King into play we see
Bishop d8 now Fabi rerouting to some
better squares even the e7 Square as
well
rook d3 was played and now Bishop e7 and
this is really instructive stuff by
Bobby I think in this case the point
Fabi is making is that the bishop is
currently corralling both of these rooks
in tandem with the King and this is a
really important use for the minor piece
in rook end games like this that I
wanted to highlight if there are some
squares that you absolutely cannot allow
the rooks into if you're able to control
them with a minor piece then the rooks
are just never stepping to those squares
so in this case it works as a fantastic
defender of the black king by guarding
these two key squares right around the
king from the e7 square not to mention
these other squares that it controls are
kind of nice as a little by-product but
the main point is it's protecting this
King from any threat of these checks
rook h2 was played in the game and what
do you expect Bobby played here it's
bishop guards this square why not guard
this square - it's a perfect defender of
the black King against the rooks g5
played in the game trying to make this
extra pawn felts but just to Rick's e2
played by Fabi rook d2 d2 in the game
rook B to c8 kingi 4 we see rook to c4
check excuse me
king of three and now King up to f5
ready to sort of recapture
at least one of these punts at some
point Rick hd2 was played back to see to
was played keeping this king boxed out
now East six yeah on the board rook
takes D to Rick takes D to F takes c6
and this still I will admit is just a
drawn position but it's definitely Fabi
with the winning chances I would say
rook d3 rook b8 is now sort of forced to
corral this pawn notably a move like
rook d7 might have been a little bit
more accurate going for some active play
against the king rather than trying to
just attack this pawn still not a huge
deal though rook b8 defends the pawn
Ricky three attacks this pawn Ricky six
defends this pawn or if back to e1 and
now King takes g5 Fabi is cleanly up
upon at the end of the day kingi for
Bishop d6 Bishop T for work over to a6
King D and Fabi takes a second pawn and
now ROG buff is just very much aiming
for the bishop and rook against rook end
game here he decided that was his best
chance and in fact he's able to achieve
it which is why he was so happy to
sacrifice these pawns rook be one d4
rather a5 sorry Bishop c5 c6 that should
be through check King g4 and he takes
one pawn off the board
King f3 he actually just goes Bishop d4
and ready to immediately capture the
second pot with Bishop takes e5 and then
Fabi went on to to win this endgame I'm
not gonna go through it because I don't
understand these bishop Android versus
rook end games so I'm not one to really
talk about it but just to fast forward
he chased the King all over the board
right to left up to down and eventually
the King ended up here and believe it or
not in this position
there is one legal move and that draws
for white and it's not the move played
in the game turns out rook g3 is the
move played in the game that loses rook
g2 draws and I'm not really going to go
over why it has to do with coming the C
2 square and checking from the side I
believe
whereas the c3 square would be covered
it's all a little bit you know crazy but
Rick b2 rook g2 not played in the game
or g3 played in the game rather and now
Rick a7 and this was the unfortunate
demise of the White King getting
corralled on g1 but the important parts
of this end game that I wanted to talk
about is first of all this me v break
this is a really great idea for plaque
and even more importantly than that I
wanted to introduce this idea of looking
at the active ideas for both sides the
active plans and using that as a way to
evaluate the position rather than using
basic principles that you guys were sort
of listing so look for active ways of
improving the pieces for both sides and
that's how you can kind of determine
which side you would rather have you
look at the active plans and then you
kind of determine which ones are coming
through with more force and more often
than not that'll lead you to some kind
of conclusion of which side you would
rather be I think that just about does
it for us
here okay the chat room is arguing with
each other and not with me always good
to see thank you so much for joining me
on this episode of the endgame class if
you're watching live be sure to head
over to the twitch channel where we will
do an episode of analyze your games if
you're watching the YouTube video that's
it for me here on youtube thank you guys
so much for joining me my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you